this season two finale of Rapunzel's
tangled adventure left us with our
mouths wide open
we can't get over Eugene's past it's
totally shocking we've delved into
Eugene's backstory and come up with some
very startling revelations watch until
the very end to find out which group of
people help Disney animators come up
with Eugene's classic look don't want
you scaring and giving up on this whole
endeavor now do know is Eugene Eugene
Fitzherbert is Rapunzel's love interest
from the tangled franchise and let's be
honest he's pretty perfect when we first
meet Eugene he goes by the name Flynn
Rider he's a thief and he's pretty good
at it
one day while running away from the
guards of Corona he ends up in
Rapunzel's tower he agrees to help her
escape to see the floating lanterns
wryly he just wants to steal the crown
of the lost princess but along the way
the two totally fall in love the movie
tells us a little more about his past
like his real name we'll get into all
those gritty details soon he saves
Rapunzel and she saves him they get
married in a short film called tingled
ever after but then Disney released a TV
show starring Rapunzel and Eugene
Rapunzel spent her entire life locked up
in a tower so despite loving Eugene with
all of her heart she just doesn't want
to rush into marriage she wants to
experience life and freedom first and
Eugene totally understands they go on to
learn about the dark rocks that threaten
Corona and Eugene continuously proves
himself to be super brave and dedicated
to Rapunzel he might be one of the
greatest disney love interests of all
time
Eugene's childhood eugene spent most of
his childhood in an orphanage he doesn't
remember his parents or his life before
he was an orphan his earliest memories
happen at the orphanage which is really
sad I used to imagine they were
swashbuckling explorers searching the
world for treasure and once
they come back and get me that doesn't
seem like a good reason to abandon your
kid in an orphanage but as long as it
reassured Eugene then it's a pretty
great story every night Eugene would
read stories about a fictional hero
named Flanagan writer it was his way for
him to escape his sad reality Flanagan
writer was his hero he wanted to be just
like him eventually he and Arden Waldo
decided to leave their life as orphans
behind earn Waldo changed his name to
Lance Strongbow Eugene changed his name
to Flynn Rider the two set out on
adventures and became really successful
thieves life as a thief Eugene who now
was known to the world as Flynn proved
himself to be a natural crook he became
an amazing fighter and a super skilled
swordsman and let's just say he's not
too shabby when it comes to riding
horses well until he meets Maximus that
is Flynn and lance become the most
feared thieves in Corona their names are
well known but these don't make friends
very easily I don't need a thief's
friend come on at one point they steal a
ring from Queen Ariana it's never a good
idea to end up on the Queen's bad side
they also get double-crossed by the
Baron despite his name the Baron isn't a
real royal he's a criminal kingpin and
he's not the guy to have as your enemy
Eugene dates the Barons daughter a woman
named Stalin but he ends up leaving her
at the altar this really angers the
Baron he betrays Flynn and Lance during
a heist involving two nobles Corona
isn't the only Kingdom that's keeping an
eye out for the wanted criminal Flynn
Rider he travels the world because he
loves nothing more than a good adventure
he travels all the way to Italy and gets
into mischief there he learns to speak
Italian Flynn is actually a really smart
guy he just doesn't always do the right
thing eventually he and Lance get
separated
Lance ends up going to prison they don't
see each other for eight years by the
time they meet again Eugene has turned
into one of the good guys
after losing touch with Lance Lynn stays
pretty isolated he teams up with other
criminals when he has to do for a job
however he mostly prefers to work
independently he wants nothing more than
to enjoy his wealth and alone time
meeting Rapunzel's Flynn's whole life
gets turned upside down when he meets
Rapunzel Flynn was in the middle of a
job with the stabbington brothers
stabbington that does not sound like the
type of people you want across they were
trying to steal the crown of the lost
princess from the castle at Corona Flynn
and his sarcastic jokes get them into
some trouble they're chased into the
forest by guards the stabbington
brothers are arrested Flynn evades
capture but he's pursued by the captain
of the guard and his horse Maximus Flynn
knocks out the captain and tries to get
away on Maximus the Maximus takes his
job very seriously he's the only horse
that Flynn can't really control they
fall over a cliff and Flynn escapes to a
tower Flynn breaks into the tower where
he's knocked out by Rapunzel when he
comes to he is tied up by her crazy long
hair she threatens to hit him with a
frying pan again he realizes that she's
totally gorgeous Flynn tries to use his
charm to win her over
but it just doesn't work take me to
these lanterns and return me home safely
then and only then will I return your
satchel he's not happy about it but he
agrees Flynn spent a while trying to get
rid of Rapunzel he deals with her
emotional rollercoaster of being free
for the first time he tries to scare her
into going home by taking her to a pub
full of criminals but Rapunzel just
befriends all of them Eugene reveals
that his only dream is to own an island
someplace warm and sunny where he can
enjoy his riches but he starts to see
something more in Rapunzel when the
guards show up along with the
stabbington brothers Flynn and Rapunzel
escape then they're in danger of
drowning in a cave he gets sentimental
as he thinks they're about to die he
tells her a puntal that his real name is
Eugene Fitzherbert because someone
deserves to know the truth Rapunzel
sings the incantation for her hair and
they're saved he's freaked out up first
by her magical hair but at this point he
already has feelings for her he tells
her about his childhood in the orphanage
the two almost kiss on the boat with the
floating lanterns in the background
Rapunzel gives him back the satchel but
he says he's found something more
important her Rapunzel and Eugene's real
adventure begins after the
defeat Mother Gothel and return to
Corona tangled adventure eugene loves
his new life in the castle with rapunzel
but she isn't quite so sure about it
he pressures her into accepting a
marriage proposal but once he realizes
that she needs more time he apologizes
for pressuring her he and Cassandra
Rapunzel's handmaiden don't really like
each other but since they both care for
Rapunzel they manage to get along well
enough lance Eugene's lifelong friend
returns he wants his old deep friend to
help with a heist but Eugene gets him to
reform he becomes one of Rapunzel's most
loyal friends in season two and Rapunzel
goes to stop the black rocks
Eugene and Lance accompany her they run
into the barren Eugene's old enemy the
Barons daughter still wants to marry
Flynn even though he left her at the
altar the barren poisoned Lance and says
he'll only give the antidote after
Eugene marries his daughter he's torn
he loves Rapunzel but wants to save
Lance so he agrees to marry her but
Rapunzel crashes the wedding and saves
the day he helps the Rapunzel find the
missing pieces of the Lord to manitous
his scroll to find the moonstone a
shocking discovery
when Rapunzel Eugene and the gang make
it to the Dark Kingdom things go very
wrong Eugene has already received a
warning that someone will betray
Rapunzel he thinks it's Cassandra but
Rapunzel doesn't Eugene ends up
separated from the others at the Dark
Kingdom he encounters a mysterious
fighter disguised as a bear and it
happens to be King Edmund the ruler of
the Dark Kingdom he reveals that he's
Eugene's father we don't know about you
but we were totally shocked he explains
how the black rocks destroyed his entire
kingdom and he tells Eugene about his
mother's passing
Edmund ordered the whole kingdom to
evacuate he sent Eugene away to go
somewhere see a servant woman took him
to the orphanage he wanted to protect
Eugene from the moonstone opal
he told Eugene it's his duty to keep
anyone from taking the opal at first
Eugene fears that the opal will kill
Rapunzel like it did his mother but his
faith in Rapunzel and the Sun Drop is
too strong he convinces his father that
Rapunzel is the only one who can end the
destruction unfortunately Cassandra soon
betrays them all and takes the moonstone
for herself
happily ever after we don't know what's
going to happen in the third and final
season of Rapunzel's tangled adventure
but we do know that Eugene and Rapunzel
have a happily ever after they
eventually get married and we know that
Rapunzel's hair is back to being
brunette entangled ever after Eugene
jokes
Eugene I'm kidding but then he gets
sentimental and says it was the best day
of his life only two things go wrong
Eugene snows is not drawn properly which
is a hilarious joke throughout the movie
and series and the skull and Maximus
lose the wedding rings should they
really have trusted a lizard and a horse
with rings probably not the two animal
companions embark on a super hilarious
adventure to locate the missing rings
they do and Eugene and Rapunzel get
married the short film ends with the
wedding cake rolling away and Eugene
joking about it typical Eugene we're so
glad these two gets a happily ever after
they deserve plus Eugenia's actually a
royal in his own right he was a lost
prince and Rapunzel was a lost princess
they're totally perfect for each other
and Eugene deserves life as a prince
from the tingled movie we know that
Rapunzel eventually rules Corona so
he'll probably become king we just can't
wait to see how season 3 plays out the
hot man meeting plenty of fans agree
that Eugene is one of the most
attractive Disney love interests out of
the bunch
but how did Disney animators make him so
darn perfect well they asked a bunch of
women the character designers had a
focus group meetings they got all the
women from the studio into one room and
asked them to describe the perfect man
the used photo and video footage and the
women said what they liked and what they
didn't like
they even got tips on his personality
then they combined all of this
information and created Flynn Rider
aka Eugene Fitzherbert it definitely
worked Eugene is one of the best
characters he and Rapunzel have a great
relationship he saved her sometimes but
she also saves him he respects her and
let her live the life she wants to lead
it may take place a long time ago but
these two are a modern couple if we've
ever seen one and we think they're our
hashtag relationshipgoals
we
really love Eugene's character art
throughout the franchise he starts as a
thief who loves money more than anything
but Rapunzel shows him there is so much
more to life he turns into a real hero
throughout the series and we love that
we know his real origin story now it
makes total sense that he's a prince
he's got the charm and the love of all
things fancy we can't wait to see how
Eugene and Rapunzel defeat Cassandra in
the new season it's going to be epic
what do you think will happen in season
three of Rapunzel's tangled adventure
let us know your theories in the
comments section below and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
think Pascal and Maximus are the cutest
BFFs ever for more videos like this one
subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]